okay we are breaking into brussels now
when nato secretary general jens
stoltenberg is speaking to the media
after the military alliance met in the
belgian capital to discuss the war in
ukraine let's listen
uh summit
of nato leaders to address the biggest
threat to our security in a generation
president putin's war against ukraine
the people of ukraine are assisting with
the courage and determination
fighting for the freedom and for their
future
we stand with them
presidency addressed us with an
impassioned message
thanking nato allies for the significant
support we are providing
and stressing the vital importance of
even more military assistance
today
natoli disagreed that we must
and will provide further
support to ukraine
we will continue to impose unprecedented
costs on russia
and we will reinforce
allied deterrence and defense
leaders approved
our four new battle groups in bulgaria
hungary romania and slovakia these are
in addition to the four already in the
baltic countries and poland
so we have eight uh multinational uh
nato battle groups
now from the
baltic sea to the black sea
across europe there are 100 000 us
troops
supporting nato efforts
and european allies and canada have also
stepped up
we have 40 000 forces under direct nato
command
mostly in the eastern part of the
alliance
backed by
major air and naval power
including an unprecedented five carrier
strike groups
from the high north to the mediterranean
today nato leaders agreed to reset our
returns and defence for the longer term
to face a new security reality
on land
we will have substantially more forces
in the eastern part of the alliance
at higher readiness
with more pre-positioned equipment and
supplies
in the air
we will deploy more jets and strengthen
our integrated air and missile defense
at sea we will have
carrier strike groups submarines
and significant numbers of combat ships
on a persistent basis
we will also strengthen our cyber
defenses
and enhance our exercises
focusing on collective defense
and interoperability
i expect we will decide on the details
at our next summit in madrid in june
today
allah leaders also agreed to provide
further support to ukraine
helping to uphold their fundamental
right to self-defense
allies are also equipping ukraine with
significant military supplies
including anti-tank and air defense
systems and drones
which are proving highly effective
as well as substantial financial and
humanitarian aid
today we agreed to do more
including cyber security assistance
and equipment to help ukraine protect
against biological chemical radiological
and nuclear threats
this could include detection
protection and medical supplies
as well as
training for the
contamination and crisis management
we are determined to do
all we can to support ukraine
and i welcome the concrete offers
of assistance made by allies today
at the same time
we have a responsibility to ensure the
conflict does not escalate further
because this would
be even more dangerous
and more devastating
allies agreed that we must also increase
our support for other partners at risk
from russia um and
from
at risk from russian threats and
interference including georgia and
bosnia and herzegovina
working together and with
the european union we must help them
uphold their sovereignty and strengthen
their resilience
we also addressed beijing's role in the
crisis today allied leaders called on
china to refrain from supporting
russia's war effort
china must not provide economic or
military support for the russian
invasion instead beijing should use its
significant influence on russia
and promote
an
immediate peaceful resolution
allies also agree that belarus must stop
acting as an accomplice to putin's
invasion
at today's meeting leaders reaffirmed
strong our strong commitment to nato's
open door policy under article 10 of the
washington treaty
nato enlargement has been an historic
success
spreading democracy freedom and
prosperity across europe
one month
since the start of russia's invasion of
ukraine
nato's security environment has
fundamentally changed for the long haul
and we are responding
but security but security does not come
for free
and doing war will cost more
so nato leaders agreed to re-double
efforts
to meet the defence investment pledge we
made in 2014
allies will submit additional plans on
how to meet the pledge in time for the
madrid summit in june
and i welcome that the number of allies
today announced plans for significant
increases
in defence spending
at this dangerous time transatlantic
unity and solate
are vital europe and north america are
standing and will continue to stand
strong together in nato i mean that i'm
going to take your questions
okay cnn
hi mr secretary general thank you um
president zelinski in his address to
nato accused russia of deploying
phosphorus munitions i'm wondering
whether nato has seen evidence of that
and what your response is or would be
and then i'm wondering did you discuss
during this meeting a permanent basing
of forces in any of these countries such
as the baltics
and abandoning the nato-russia founding
act
so we are resetting nato's returns and
defense for the long term
uh with more troops uh with more air
assets and more maritime capabilities
we have already increased our presence
in the east and today we decided on four
new battle groups and the leaders uh
agreed to task our military commanders
to provide options
uh for a long-term reset of our presence
our military posture in the eastern part
of the alliance and across the whole
alliance
details will be then decided at our
summit in june but that comes on top of
what we have already done so this is uh
long term we are prepared for long haul
because um
uh we can all today say
that um
that
the russia invasion president putin's
invasion of ukraine
has changed our security environment
for the long term it's a new reality
it's uh it's uh it's a new normal and
nato is responding for the long term
we have seen
very credible reports about
the use of
also the use of military force against
civilians
and of course this is a great concern
for all nato allies
nbc
secretary general thank you for taking
my question how do you believe nato will
respond if china begins to support
russia economically and perhaps with
military supplies and also do you
believe that there's a role to play
for nato when it comes to alleviating
energy costs and i'm talking about
speaking directly to saudi arabia and
other opec producers thank you
nato allies are coordinating their
efforts when it comes to also energy
security and it was also addressed in a
meeting today
to
step up supplies to diversify
uh
sources of supply and uh
and also us to reduce dependence on
supplies from from russia uh and uh and
later on today i also participate in the
g7 meeting and of course in different
frameworks g7 working with the eu uh
there are different formats where nato
allies address the need uh to strengthen
energy security and reduce dependence on
on on russian oil and
gas
our message to china is that they should
join the rest of the world and clearly
condemn
the brutal war against
ukraine uh and not support uh
russia
neither with
with uh economic support or of course
not with military support okay we'll go
to interface ukraine late in the second
row
general news agency interface ukraine i
would like to ask you if polish
leadership put at the table today for
discussion the proposal to send
peacekeeping mission to ukraine and if
yes what kind of discussion it was and
is there is some conclusion thank you
as we discussed a wide range of uh
issues
and
uh and the message is that we have to
stand united
and also that we need to provide support
to ukraine but at the same time we have
a responsibility
to ensure that this conflict do not
become a full-fledged war
between nato and russia and
and that's also reason why allies have
may declare that we will not deploy
troops on the ground in
in ukraine uh because uh
the only
uh way to do that is to be prepared to
engage in full
uh conflict uh with russian troops
okay financial times
thank you very much secretary general
congratulations on your annual extension
um you said in the statement that allies
agreed to enhance preparedness and
readiness for chemical biological
radiological and nuclear
threats is that based on credible
intelligence that those threats could be
imminent and how does the alliance
strengthen its protection against those
threats thank you
so we are concerned um partly because we
see the rhetoric
and we see that russia is trying to
create some kind of pretext accusing
ukraine united states nato allies for
preparing to use uh chemical and
biological weapons and we have seen
before that this uh
uh way of accusing others is actually a
way to create to create a pretext for do
the same uh themselves
uh and and of course their accusations
against the ukraine and nato allies are
absolutely false
[Music]
any use of chemical
weapons will
totally change the nature of the
conflict it will be a blatant violation
of international law
and
it will have
wide spread consequences
and of course be extremely dangerous
it will
affect the people in ukraine but there's
also a risk that will have a direct
effect on people living in nato
countries because
we can see contamination we can see the
spread of
chemical agents or
biological weapons into our countries
we also know that russia has used
chemical agents against its own
opposition
and they have used it on nato territory
in salisbury before and we also know
that russia has facilitated supported
the assad regime in syria
when they used chemical weapons against
their own population
so this just highlights the importance
of uh ending this war immediately
because this is a dangerous situation
and therefore we impose the sanctions so
we if we support ukraine
allies agreed to supply equipment to
help ukraine protect against chemical
biological radiological and nuclear
threats
this could include
detection equipment protection and
medical support as well as training
for the
contamination and crisis management
we are also enhancing allies
preparedness and readiness for chemical
and biological and nuclear threats
our top military commander general
walters has activated nato's chemical
biological
radiological and nuclear defense
elements
and allies are deploying additional
chemical and biological and nuclear
defenses to reinforce our existing and
new battle groups so we are taking
measures both to support ukraine and
also to defend ourselves okay we'll go
to al jazeera
secretary general james bayes from al
jazeera president zielenski when he
addressed you recall the fact he first
spoke to you a month ago and he says he
didn't get clear answers
so this time he asked you specifically
for one percent of all your tanks for
one percent of all your aircraft for
multi-launch rocket systems anti-ship
weapons and means of air defense a very
specific list what is your clear answer
we all listened very carefully to
president zelensky and many of the
leaders in the room
have had contact with him over these
weeks i also spoke with him and
under the ukrainian defenseman
participated in our defense ministerial
meeting last week we listened carefully
and of course we took note of his very
compassionate message to all nato allies
nato allies provide significant support
to ukraine
and we provide also lethal weapons
advanced systems
and also systems that help them to
shoot down planes
and
attack
battle tanks with anti-tank weapons and
many other types of
of systems including drones i will not
go into the details of the exact type of
systems we are deploying this close
contact between nato allies and ukraine
but what i can say is that allies do
what they can to support ukraine with
weapons so ukraine can defend themselves
as self-defense is a right enshrined in
you and charter
at the same time we have a
responsibility
to
prevent this conflict from becoming a
full-fledged war in europe involving not
only ukraine and russia but
nato allies and russia that will be more
dangerous and more devastating and
and i think we have to be honest about
that and that's exactly what we have
been in our meeting today and also what
i say to you
in the press conference now
well what we do is that we are
delivering a lot of uh
uh equipment and that is an answer but i
will not go into the details i don't
think that's the wise for operational
reasons if i listed exactly what and
when and how
we are delivering uh essential equipment
to ukraine nato allies have stepped up
and is essential for the progress they
have been able to make in the fight
against
the invading russian forces thank you
very much colleagues i know there are
many questions i'm afraid the secretary
general needs to go to the g7 meeting
but there will be other briefings
throughout the day thank you so much
thank you
okay that was nato secretary general yen
stoltenberg addressing the media after a
meeting of nato leaders which lasted
more than three hours his press
conference was delayed by at least an
hour ukrainian president vladimir
zelinsky addressed the leaders virtually
in that meeting which was closed to the
press
he called for more military aid and had
a very specific list of requests
uh all this comes as today marks a month
of russia's invasion of ukraine the
schedule in brussels is jammed packed
with three summits taking place
the meeting of nato allies which we just
heard from jen stoltenberg about as well
as a meeting of g7 leaders which is
happening now and then followed by a
meeting of eu leaders so nato secretary
general jen stoltenberg just spoke to
the media then about how nato has agreed
to provide more military support to
ukraine
for the longer term he spoke
specifically about four areas he said
that more forces will be deployed on the
ground in eastern europe he went on to
say that more assets will also be used
in the air
at sea by way of combat ships and
submarines will be deployed he also said
that the alliance will strengthen its
cyber defenses
he said the details
of these uh
four specific areas will be finalized in
madrid at a summit in june
he said that the allies are also
preparing for the potential for russia
to use chemical weapons so that was nato
secretary general ian stoltenberg
speaking to the media after a meeting of
nato leaders in brussels u.s president
joe biden is there he's there in an
effort to keep america's allies united
against russia's war in ukraine so after
that meeting of nato allies it will be
followed by the g7 and then eu leaders
he faces steep challenges the u.s
president as the allies seek new
measures to punish russian president
vladimir putin to break it all down for
us let's bring in our diplomatic editor
james bayes who is in brussels and was
inside
that press conference james promises of
more military support
what from nato will it provide ukraine's
president with what he asked for
no because ukraine's president made it
quite clear the specifics that he wanted
to see
from
nato he said that the thing that had
pained him most a month ago when he'd
he'd first put his request particularly
his request to try and stop uh russian
aircraft which he said because they had
no means of stopping them they're
effectively a weapon of mass destruction
he said uh that
what they really needed a clear answer
from nato on very specific requests and
he made very specific requests in his
speech in his address i'm not sure
whether nato leaders expected that
speech to be made public but it was the
ukrainian mission to the united nations
and then the ukrainian president's
office put out the video which you've
seen of that speech
mr stoltenberg yes says they will have
done a great deal which is true and he
says they'll do more but he wouldn't
answer on those specifics his reason
despite the fact that president zulenski
asked for a clear answer is because that
would be giving information uh to russia
what we did get more details of is what
nato is going to do to protect itself
again i think they were um green
lighting things that are already in
progress uh we now have eight battle
groups that are in the country's closest
to russia on that eastern flank
of nato four of them didn't exist before
the invasion they've been put into place
now
so
progress i think some progress
but not what the ukrainians would have
wanted the other bit of news we got from
this was about mr stoltenberg himself he
tweeted just moments before that news
conference and as the final communique
from this first of three summits came
out of that he was staying on he's going
to meet the un's at the un the nato
secretary general for another year his
term extended into 2023 so there is a
there is the same continuity uh at this
time
of crisis uh mr stoltenberg actually who
is norwegian former norwegian prime
minister was going to return to his
country to be norway's central bank
governor well he's going to stay at the
helm of nato
for another year one year extension all
right thank you very much for bringing
us up to speed there james bay is our
diplomatic editor in brussels let's
bring in bad chef chick now who's also
in brussels and has been listening in on
to that press conference he's a visiting
senior fellow at the german martial fund
so we heard from the secretary general
jen stoltenberg about what they're going
to provide further in terms of military
what did you make of what he said and
that
in comparison to what the ukrainian
president actually asked for
well thanks for having me
this is you know an illustration of a
unified west in action and it's
quite remarkable how quickly things have
been put together
within nato
by last count you had something like 30
nato allies and partners providing
weapons to ukraine very sophisticated
weapons javelin anti-tank missiles
anti-aircraft missiles and now even
anti-aircraft batteries which can reach
higher
and with more lethality
now i very much appreciate the
sensitivities around all the individual
supplies and not wanting to disclose the
operational details
to be fair um ukraine
and president zielinski is always going
to request more because they're acting
they're participating in an active uh
conflict act of hot war
defending their territory and so
i think nato and nato allies and
partners have provided tremendous amount
of support which is why
well partly why
the ukrainian defense forces have been
able to resist and heroically perform
on the battlefield and this will
continue uh you know this aid will not
stop
until ukraine is able to prevail
but another thing that stood out for me
from that press conference was the
discussion around chemical and or
biological weapons
a team has been pulled together in the
us in the event chemical or biological
weapons are used by russia and
interestingly nato is doing the same so
this really is quite a huge concern for
the alliance
it is a huge concern because the use of
chemical weapons which is by the way
um you know has been witnessed in recent
past unfortunately through the use of
chemical weapons in syria but also by
russia on european soil and going after
its own political opponents you know
this is a real threat uh the
intelligence reports about uh russia
accusing ukraine of launching such an
attack um as a sort of false flag
operation
and uh so yes this is a a very
considerable
risk as well as the unthinkable uh but
also
plausible risk of the use of tactical
nuclear weapon and so both
are obviously scenarios which would
elevate this conflict to a significantly
different stage now
both president biden and nato leaders
across the board have
emphasized that this would
yield severe consequences against russia
and you don't want to get into the
specific hypotheticals because all the
depends on the specific circumstance and
um again we want to avert this from
happening in the first place
uh but yes you see
nato allies and partners uh preparing
for this uh uh unthinkable scenario and
supporting ukraine to be able to be
ready for it as well
but um what we're seeing in brussels is
really a picture of unity but there are
fractions beneath the surface of that so
not do you believe that not everyone is
necessarily on the same page when it
comes to sanctioning russia
well look this is another element of
policy that's had had
tremendous
consensus and support across the board
not only
among the nato allies and partners but
across the world
countries such as japan south korea
australia all supporting the sanctions
regimes
that have been developed in
collaboration with eu countries the uk
and the united states and canada
now
it's also fair to say that some of the
measures envisioned in terms of uh
sanctions against gas imports
or oil imports will have differential
economic effects on different countries
that are
launching sanctions and so you want to
strike a fine balance between exerting
incredible economic leverage against
russia and at the same time make sure
that you don't um uh hamper your own
economies uh in a way that will be
disadvanta disadvantageous and so you
know these technical discussions are are
going on the eu for its part has
committed to
getting off
russia's gas
supplies as well as oil
supplies over time
limiting gas imports by significant
amount over the next 12 months but these
are difficult um issues to actually
implement in practice and people are
very much hard at work to try to figure
out the details they certainly are thank
you for breaking it all down for us but
chef chick in brussels a visiting senior
fellow at the german marshall fund
thanks for your time on this newshour
my pleasure